well you know in a way it is surprising
that it has been possible for strong
influential sectors or even companies or
groups of companies to make such an
impact in undermining or countering the
scientific evidence that has been
mounting so a lot of effort has gone in
to try to undermine reality now why is
it being listened to this is hard to
understand but the fact of the matter is
that a lot of resources a lot of
thinking and a lot of money has gone
into trying to influence the world in
the negative way and you know this is
well we have the same issue with the
tobacco companies if we go back well
it's not over but at least it became
clear to many that the tobacco companies
in fact we're misbehaving lying to the
US Congress and putting a lot of effort
into undermining public health efforts
so I think we have an aspect of this
also with regard to climate change